so this is NG house 2. through the fog
is a glimpse of the future of our homes
and how we power them it's -13 inside
the University of salford's energy house
lab the whole purpose of this lab is to
take buildings through different
climates
here they're experimenting with how to
build and heat zero carbon homes without
blackouts or homeowners breaking the
bank with the National Grid asking some
customers to manually power down their
homes in future that could be automated
some vehicles and some operators will
will let us use the battery that's in
here to power the house which is next to
us the future could be driving around
with this huge power plant sat outside
our house so we could make better use of
that in the future inside one of the
experimental homes is an array of
different heating options radiators
powered by an air source heat pump
electric infrared heaters and underfloor
heating all connected to a smart meter
to understand which works best at lowest
cost and with lowest demand for grid
power up in the Loft there's a new kind
of air source heat pump solar panels a
battery for storing electricity all of
which talk to the smart meter of the
house and then on to the National Grid
but all of this is really expensive kit
that's going to need to be rolled out
widely if we're going to manage energy
demands and hit our Net Zero targets and
that future is some way off with only
around 50 percent of customers even on a
smart meter so what needs to change it's
about making sure we've got good
connections it's about removing planning
barriers for people to get heat pumps in
their homes and it's about making sure
that our energy markets reflect the fact
that Renewables are going to be the
incumbent form of generation this is
quite geeky work but that's what we need
government to do and until they do it we
can't offer these services to ordinary
people in their homes
we have the technology to make a low
carbon electricity system that's stable
whatever the weather what we don't have
yet are the policies and price points to
deliver it Tom Clark Sky News Salford